Lìa cho một cái đồng chiến lấy đầu,
quyền lấy đầu đàn nhà nước,
viết bị đại biểu khách quý,
đã về thông sự lấy kỳ điện,
bởi mấy lâm năm ngày báo nhân dần ra số đầu
và đón nhận khoảng trường lòng đầu hạm nhất Ngày Hô Ngài.
Bởi lòng nợ.
Bởi tất cả những phía dần và sử lấy đàn của đàn,
sự mổ giúp đợi của các bộ mang ngàn chúng tôi mởi hiệu phương.
Mọi người dần sẽ thiết được không ngừng phát triển,
đúng có, thây dựng và sử dụng khách mạnh của đàn.
Bởi tất cả trăm tỉnh đến mỗi cùng cường phổn vinh thành phúc.
Nhân dần màu chúng ta đàn hay nhà nước,
của bạn là Nhân dần giúp liệu chính là thành quyết mới,
giúp liệu là tuyệu sạch sợp mới,
và giữ liệu chính là một trong chủ cột của hoàn nhân dần.
Trong thành chình chúng tôi chuyển số.
Nhân chỉ liệu mấy mình không lòng.
Ngày báo nhân dần ra số đầu.
Bạn Nhân nước là có định tháng cường.
Bộ nhân dần ra số đầu.
Chúng tôi chuyển tưởng trang của chuyển cũng kích mạnh mạnh mạnh mạnh.
Nhưng người đã mở như rất tưởng phát triển kinh nghiệp,
tưởng hảo, khảm địa, tiêm tiêm, bộ phí tâm,
là sự trang đẹp mạnh, tình chiến trị.
Nên cao chỉ là một chuyến mốt.
Nếu được vua lên đặt, đặt, như cậu,
vua yh có phần của trang nạn, con trơn,
có phần của trang có tà, để trị tháng lợp,
tị phết đại ở trang đứa bộ n của đàn.
Vì một tiêu xây được lực của bạn, quà bên giọc lập, rất trụ gâu mạnh, quà bên vình, quang lình, hạnh phúc, rượu bước đi lên trụ biệt sỏi.
Phấn đấu, thật sự là mọi người, chính trị tuyệt đồ đạc, khiến mặt tạp, ảo chí, xung đáng, quý nhớ, như nếu của đạc, giết lực, hãy dân.